a war-torn country now isolated from its
neighbors
there's a sense of panic and anger
spreading in mali's capital bamako
people rushed to banks petrol stations
and markets for provisions after the
west african body ecowas announced a
raft of sanctions including the closing
of air in land borders and the halting
of financial transactions with west
african countries
mali won't be able to withstand the
latest sanctions we don't have access to
the ocean and we need the ports of
senegal and ivory coast to get goods
into our country for business owners the
economic sanctions are suicidal
in december the transitional government
led by the military gentle leader asimi
goethe said it would delay presidential
elections scheduled in february to
another five years following national
consultations on sunday dismayed west
african heads of state gathered to
impose further sanctions on mali asking
for a return to civilian rule
as much as we are aware of the complex
situation in the country we think that
all political economical and social
reforms looking to reshape mali can only
be headed by democratically elected
authorities
goita orchestrated two successive coups
in 2020 and in 2021 after detaining the
president and prime minister he named
himself president of mali's transition
his transitional government was quick to
denounce the west african sanctions with
this announcement made on national
television
we condemn these sanctions that are
unequal and illegitimate it's curious
that these sanctions come at a time when
the malian army are making spectacular
progress in the fight against terrorism
it's almost 10 years since french forces
intervened in northern mali to repel
armed groups linked to al-qaeda despite
their presence and 14 000 u.n
peacekeepers the security situation has
deteriorated
dramatically millions of malians are
displaced unable to return home groups
linked to isil and al-qaeda or gaining
grounds in central mali
asimi goethe's government hired russian
fighters to help tackle the security
situation much to the ire of the former
colonial power france who announced a
withdrawal of troops for the country's
leadership bringing lasting peace to
mali means a few sacrifices and changing
its relationship with both france and
its neighbors
no matter the cost
nicholas hawk al jazeera